précisément des idées de sorties pour ce
week end avec l'agenda
au programme ce soir de l'art
contemporain à tour un concert de jazz à
blois mais deux suites rencontre en
musique avec françois cornut le festival
carré d'as c'est lui et il a une
prédilection pour chopin écouter
[Musique]
françois nous a donné rendez vous entre
deux répétitions pour ce nocturnes de
chopin il l'interprète samedi à chartres
au festival carré d'as qui fête sa 20e
édition
allegro comme brio
il y aura beaucoup de valls il y aura
des nocturnes
une étude est la troisième balade donc
tout cela de chopin dans un programme
que j'ai intitulé chopin forever
au festival carré d'as on s'y presse
aussi pour écouter les jeunes talents
c'est devenu au fil du temps une sorte
de tremplin de la musique classique
ce festival a pour vocation de présenter
des jeunes concertistes mais qui sont en
début de carrière et le plus souvent
plutôt soliste donc des pianistes
violence et violoniste janséniste
chanteur notamment
on a des grands talents qui sont qui
sont passés par le festival carré d'as
david bismuth françois dumont sont des
très grands pianistes maintenant qu'ils
parcourent le monde dans sur les grandes
scènes ils vont faire partie de la
sélection des artistes pour les folles
journées de nantes par exemple de la
roque d'anthéron c'est vraiment ça fait
plaisir de les revoir
[Applaudissements]
dimanche à dreux pour le deuxième
concert de ce week end les ensembles
s'étoffe de chanteurs de flûtistes et de
saxophonistes issus des écoles de
musique d'eure-et-loir et cette fois
fille de frédéric chopin
ce sont mozart schubert et astor
piazolla qui sont annoncés
[Musique]
sarah mackenzie se produit dimanche aux
lobbies à blois
la pianiste australienne est une adepte
du swing et elle adore paris où elle
s'est installée
ce concert c'est comme un très joli clin
d'oeil adressé à woody allen et à ses
musiques de films à orléans la
chorégraphe séverine chavrier donne
plusieurs représentations de sa dernière
création
après coup ou le destin de trois femmes
qui se fraie un chemin à travers des
tyrannie exercée sur le deuxième sexe on
file à tour avec cette pièce de claus
rinke exposé au cc cod l'instrumentarium
dans ses veines coule l'eau de 12
rivières et fleuves européens le tage
l'odeur la scène le tibre 12 fleuve
excepté la tamise une façon pour
l'artiste allemand de manifester sa
mauvaise humeur contre le break site
dans l'art et politiques tous
[Musique]